وفي المعارك على الارض اعلنت وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه السيطره على بلده كليشكا الواقعه
الجنوبيه بخمت في منطقه دونيت شرقي
اوكرانيا
وكانت ميليشيا فاجنر الروسيه اعلنت امس
سيطرتها على البلده التي تقع على بعد تسعه
كيلو مترات جانبي ضخمه والتي كان عدد
سكانها قبل الحرب نحو 400,000 شخص
اقدر في البلده معركه استنزاف استمرت
شهورا مع القوه الاكرانيه
في الاثناء اعلى نتائج الامم المتحده وصول
اول قافله مساعدات انسانيه امميه الى محيط
بلده سوليدار التي تقع ايضا ضمن محور ضخمه
القتاليه وقال يانس لاكي الناطق باسمي
مكتب الامم المتحده لتنسيق المساعدات
الانسانيه هنا قافله المساعدات تضم ثلاثه
شاحنات تنقل المياه والاغذيه والسلع عن
اساسيه لنحو 800 شخص وانا بدات تفريغ
حمولتها في المدينه